RIGHT NOW IT'S TIME TO PLAY
WRASTLIN' VIDEOS.
(CHEERING)
(WHISTLING, WHOOPING)
IN HONOR OF OUR ARTIST IN
RESIDENCE THIS WEEK, MR. RON
FUNCHES, WE WANTED TO PLAY A
GAME ABOUT HIS TRUE LOVE,
PROFESSIONAL WRESTLING.
I KNOW, I KNOW, PRO WRESTLING IS
NORMALLY SO SOLEMN AND
DIGNIFIED, HOW COULD WE POSSIBLY
MINE ANY COMEDY FROM THIS
DISTINGUISHED PURSUIT?
BUT OUR CRACK RESEARCH TEAM DUG
UP THESE VERY RARE INSTANCES OF
PRO WRESTLING FOOLISHNESS.
COMEDIANS, WE'RE GONNA SHOW YOU
SUCH A VIDEO-- FOR 250 POINTS,
YOU'RE GONNA ANSWER OUR QUESTION
ABOUT THAT WRESTLER.
AND JUST KNOW THAT THE LAST
TIME WE PLAYED THIS, RON WAS
ANSWERING THEM BEFORE THE VIDEOS
EVEN FINISHED.
(LAUGHTER)
UH, FIRST UP, THIS TAG-TEAM DUO,
THIS TAG-TEAM DUO.
(GRUNTING)
(PEOPLE SHOUTING)
(LAUGHTER)
>> THAT'S...
EVEN THE REF IS, LIKE, "WHAT THE
[BLEEP] ARE YOU DOING?!"
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: I DON'T THINK
THAT'S WRESTLING, I THINK THAT'S
JUST KICKING A CHILD.
HOW DID THEY TAUNT THEIR PRETEEN
OPPONENT BEFORE THE MATCH?
RON FUNCHES.
>> UH, FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO
GIVE A NICE "SUCK IT" AND "TOO
SWEET" TO MY BROTHERS MACK AND
NICK JACKSON.
(APPLAUSE, WHOOPING, WHISTLING)
AND I KNOW FOR A FACT MY FELLOW
BULLET CLUB MEMBERS SAID,
"HEY, WE'RE BOTH [BLEEP]IN' YOUR
MOM."
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT. POINTS.
(APPLAUSE)
NEXT, NEXT.
THE MIDNIGHT ROCKERS!
>> ♪ WE'RE THE MIDNIGHT ROCKERS
SHAWN AND MARTY
WE LOVE TO WRESTLE
♪ AND WE LOVE TO PARTY
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
WE'RE NOT GONNA FUMBLE
♪ 'CAUSE WE'LL BE SHAKING
TO THE WRESTLEROCK RUMBLE. ♪
>> HARDWICK: OH, THEY ARE
DEFINITELY WRESTLING THOSE
RHYMES.
WHAT IS A BETTER NAME FOR THIS
TEAM THAN THE MIDNIGHT ROCKERS?
YES, YASSIR LESTER.
>> I WOULD CALL THEM THE SEXY
TWIN DUDES, OR STDS FOR SHORT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS. YEP.
(WHOOPING, APPLAUSE)
POINTS. CHRIS.
>> UH, THE GUYS WHO JUST GOT
BACK FROM THE OPTOMETRIST.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE, WHOOPING)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
>> WHY THE [BLEEP] ARE THEY
WEARING THOSE GLASSES?
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: ♪ BETTER NOW?
BETTER NOW? BETTER NOW?
BETTER NOW? ♪
NEXT ONE.
HERE'S THE DIRTY PLAYER.
>> I AM COMING.
I'M COMING FOR THAT TITLE, ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER.
YOU LIKE ME OR NOT, I'M GONNA BE
MOST HATED PLAYER IN THE WORLD,
TWF AT WRESTLELUTION!
>> HARDWICK: WHAT IS THIS DIRTY
PLAYER CATCH PHRASE?
YASSIR.
>> THANK YOU FOR SHOPPING AT
WALMART.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
POINTS.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> HARDWICK: UH, CHRIS.
>> UH, HEY, IT'S ME, FRED DURST.
YOU PROBABLY DON'T RECOGNIZE
ME...
YOU...
YOU PROBABLY DON'T RECOGNIZE ME,
SINCE I'VE BEEN STRUCK BY
LIGHTNING NINE TIMES.
ALL RIGHT.
>> YOU GOT TO JUST LET IT GO.
>> ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS FOR THAT.
RON FUNCHES.
>> UH, VOTE TRUMP!
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
>> YEAH, THAT'S A GOOD ONE, TOO.
>> HARDWICK: NEXT ONE-- SHE
TRAINS THE GORGEOUS LADY OF
WRESTLING-- IT'S AUNT KITTY!
>> ♪ PLEASED TO MEET YOU, I'M
AUNT KITTY
ALL MY GIRLS ARE HOT AND PRETTY
♪ I TRAIN THEM HARD, SO IN THE
RING YOU'LL SEE MY TIGERS DO
THEIR THING. ♪
>> HARDWICK: WHAT IS AUNT
KITTY'S TRAINING REGIMEN...
YASSIR LESTER?
>> UH, MAKING RUNS TO THE PAYDAY
LOAN CENTER FOR HER BLACK
BOYFRIEND.
>> THAT IS 100% THE TRUTH.
>> I MEAN...
I'M DATING HER.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, WE'LL
GIVE YOU POINTS FOR THAT, OF
COURSE.